it touched me in a special way i ain't
felt in a long time the peaches and the
cream i told you i was a fee
what's up everybody i'm david and you
know i love a good barbecue but only on
a budget so today i'm going to show you
how to make a barbecue for four for only
twenty dollars
[Music]
[Applause]
as you can see i've already went
shopping and we got some pretty good
deals here now i did go a little bit
over budget but i think we still did
pretty good the total only came out to
20 dollars and 43 cents as always we're
gonna use a few of our pantry freebies
today we're going to be using olive oil
sugar salt and pepper well with that
let's get started
now we're going to start with this
pineapple barbecue bacon burger now
these are going to be pretty epic i mean
it's wrapped in bacon and stuffed with
cheese what more could you want the
first step is going to be to take your
ground beef and just season it to taste
with a little salt maybe about one and a
half piles or something like that you
know nothing crazy
and do the same with your pepper make
sure that you use enough since this is
gonna be for all four burgers now we're
gonna go ahead and start to incorporate
the seasoning together just use your
hands and work it in really good
and then we'll put in about a cup of
barbecue sauce want to make sure we get
all of that in there
now we chose burgers because ground beef
tends to be a little bit cheaper and
it's always a fan favorite and when you
stuff it with cheese everybody's gonna
be happy now after you've got your meat
ready you want to go ahead and section
it off into about four pieces so that
you can have four big juicy burgers
they're gonna be big we're gonna give
you that little fast food burger you'd
be having at your cousin barbecue you go
home hungry don't nobody like that and
after you get it worked into a nice
little ball we'll place it onto our
baking sheet
so then you can use a soda can or beer
can whatever you have around the house
to help you make that little crater
where we'll fill our cheese
so i'm going to go ahead and just smash
it down in there
and you want to make sure that you try
to build it up around the sides so that
you don't have any cracks in it and then
we'll take our bacon
we're gonna go ahead and just slide that
around
it's gonna get to bubbling and
baking in all over the place now you
know we're generous here so we're gonna
use two strips wrap that around
and now once you've got it all nice and
wrapped you want to take a toothpick and
just insert it wherever the bacon
overlaps so that it'll stay together as
it cooks so one right there then i'm
going to put another one on the other
side
and maybe one more over here just to be
safe and then you can lift out your can
and you should have a nice little crater
for your cheese now we decided to get a
block of cheddar cheese and cut it
ourselves rather than getting some
shredded cheese or pre-cut cheese
because it's a little cheaper now you
can also experiment with the cheese if
you want to go crazy with a little gouda
havarti or munster or whatever the
little fancy cheese is go ahead and do
it i'm not going to hate we're just
going to repeat that step three more
times and we'll be ready to put these
bad boys on the grill got my burgers
ready
i've got my pineapple slices i was lucky
enough to find a fresh pineapple went
ahead and cut it into four slices so we
have one for each burger and now we're
ready to go let's get these on the grill
so we've got our grill up to about 375
degrees i'm gonna place these burgers
over indirect heat now what that means
is we've got this left side of the grill
turned off and the right side we have
both burners on so when we close it it's
going to act just like an oven but still
give you that nice charred flavor that
we're looking for
all right we're going to baste these
with the barbecue sauce every 10 to 15
minutes you want to go ahead and just
drizzle dabble douse you know what i'm
saying all type of delicious sauce
adjectives and just let that flavor get
in there as it caramelizes and cooks
really nice and now we're going to place
our pineapples over direct heat we've
used a little paper towel just to remove
some of the excess water to make sure we
get some really nice grill marks
already smells good and we'll just let
these pineapple slices cook for about
one to two minutes per side until we
have some nice grill marks
i'm baking these for the second time
these guys are looking good
now let's go prep our sides
now i know when you're thinking
hamburgers you're thinking fries but i
wanted to put just a little bit of a
healthy spin on it besides string beans
are pretty much the french fries and
vegetables so we've got some string
beans and some potato wedges we're going
to put together now to get started with
our potato wedges you're just going to
take your potato already peeled put it
up on the side like this and cut it down
the middle now you can take that and
just cut it into some nice sized wedges
like so now we're going to take those
wedges and place them into our bowl
now when you're on a budget salt and
pepper your friend don't be all fancy
trying to get the pink himalayan and all
that this you know nice sea salt does
just fine now the peas de la rosa stars
for me you know we're always going to
teach you how to use a little seasoning
packet and today i'm excited because we
got garlic parmesan that's my favorite
thing to put on wings and all types of
things i'm going to be generous with
this one because i like it
go ahead and get that well up in there
a little extra pop pop just a little pat
on it just do a little pat like that
just look pat like that and it's gonna
go up in there good now just make sure
you get everything coated really nicely
the olive oil salt pepper and seasoning
so that it grills really nice
we'll do the same with our potato wedges
smells amazing already
and with that i think these are ready
for the grill
now that our burgers have about 15
minutes left we're gonna go ahead and
get our sides on now with these potato
wedges we're going to throw them on the
grill for about five to seven minutes
per side
that garlic parmesan seasoning packet is
gonna come in perfect i can already
smell the flavor
and now for our green beans
make sure all your veggies have even
contact with the grill we don't want to
overcrowd it so if it takes a couple
batches that's fine
we'll cook these potato wedges for about
five to seven minutes per side you'll
know they're done once you can see the
beautiful grill marks and they're easy
to pierce with a fork now that our
veggies are done we'll go ahead and get
these burgers off the grill and assemble
them all right it's time to put these
burgers together we're going to go ahead
and start with just a little bit of
lettuce on the bottom
and then we'll go ahead and get that
delicious burger
oozing with cheese
and last but not least that beautiful
charred pineapple all right
everyone's for sure gonna love these
now that our burgers are put together
we're gonna go ahead and put our side
into a nice little bowl i've decided to
garnish it with a little bit of lemon
yes flutters a little bit and got one
and we can go ahead and put some fresh
lemon juice on the top just for another
nice flavor so at this point i think i
deserve a taste let's go ahead and see
what we're working with here
definitely got to get some of these
delicious green beans
of course i'm gonna need one of these
amazing burgers all right this is pretty
big so i'm gonna go ahead and cut it in
half so i can actually get a bite out of
it now that looks like heaven
too good to be true amazing burger's
awesome let's check out these sides
mmm
amazing that garlic parmesan seasoning
packet was the perfect choice to make
this five pie y'all approved baby i mean
at this point we've spent less than
twenty dollars pretty much and we still
have dessert so let's go ahead and put
it together
and now for dessert we're gonna make
some grilled peaches and cream cinnamon
rolls i know it sounds amazing just be
patient please so to get started we've
already floured our surface and we're
going to take our cinnamon rolls here go
ahead and get them rolled out
now i've used these before you've seen
them on dollar dish many times they're
affordable delicious and you know easy
way to make some of the best dessert
so i'll go ahead and get these bad boys
out onto my surface
one more he thought he was gonna get
away but that's not gonna happen this
dollar dish we use everything now you'll
make two rows of four out of your
cinnamon rolls because we're going to
put them together and roll it out so
that we can have one large piece of
dough to work with
now once you get them lined out like
this to be honest it's probably best to
just use your hands and smash it down a
little bit now the other important part
is to try to make sure you get all those
little crevices or spaces in between
individual rolls to blend together
and you want to try to get it about
eight or so inches across now that it's
come together we're going to go ahead
and sprinkle a little bit more flour
before we roll it out just want to make
sure that it doesn't stick to our
rolling pan
now you can kind of stretch this out a
little bit just try to stretch it just
about to each end now that we've got
this all rolled out we've got some fresh
peaches here that we found in season
really great deal we're going to add
just a little bit of sugar about a
tablespoon or so to really help bring
out that sweetness in our grilled
peaches and cream cinnamon roll
now go ahead and just mix that together
let the sugar coat on them we'll go
ahead and put it onto our cinnamon roll
dough we'll try to spread out our
peaches as evenly as possible you want
to make sure you're still able to roll
up your dough after you're finished
there we go
all right now you want to carefully roll
your log make sure you tuck all those
peaches in there you want to make sure
you do it nice and tight
and maybe just use your hand to kind of
firm it up a little bit towards the end
i recommend trying to cut it in half go
ahead and cut those into halves and then
do the same with the four pieces that
you have and now that you've finished
cutting them you'll take a seven inch
wreath cast iron and you want to take
one of them and place it into the center
and then just place all seven around it
with the fruit facing up and with that
it's pretty simple these guys are ready
to go peaches and cream i need it
because you know that i'm a thing let's
go ahead and get them on the grill
now that we've got our grill set to
about 350 degrees we're gonna put these
on for about 30 to 35 minutes or so now
just like we did with our burgers we're
going to cook these over indirect heat
so that we can have an oven type of cook
with the same barbecue flavor locked
inside all right let's see what we got
here wow now these look amazing i don't
know if i'm gonna be able to share these
with everybody but um let's go ahead and
get the icing on these and finish
putting together this amazing barbecue
now what's the peaches without the cream
at this point we've definitely got to
drizzle over that nice icing that came
with our cinnamon rolls like so just to
add a delicious little topping
i can smell the peaches and cinnamon
this is going to be amazing and the
perfect end to a nice barbecue
before you try it you want to make sure
you let it cool for about five or so
minutes i mean after waiting this long
for delicious dessert you don't want to
burn your tongue
i've waited five minutes it felt kind of
like an eternity but at this point i've
definitely got to try it this looks too
good to be true
[Music]
it touched me in a special way i ain't
felt in a long time
the peaches and the cream i told you i
was a fee
that's the absolute best end to a
barbecue that i could ever think of for
only 20 we made an epic pineapple bacon
barbecue burger some super flavorful
garlic parmesan grilled veggies and an
indulgent grilled peaches and cream
cinnamon roll i hope you guys enjoyed
and can try this 20 barbecue at home and
let us know in the comments what you
want to see next on dollar dish
oh yes
[Music]
you